Epictetus discourses begin in book 1
chapter 1 by talking about what's inner
power and what's not in our power and
that's a very important topic for the
Stoics and for epictetus but that's not
where we're actually going to begin
we're going to start in book 2 chapter
11 talking about the origin or the
beginnings of philosophy as Epictetus
understands it because we're involving
ourselves in this activity along with
him of doing philosophy of trying to see
things through his vision on the world
on values on human nature so it's
probably good to have a solid
understanding of what he understands
this whole project to be now you notice
I've got these these three sets of
topics here we'll come to them fairly
soon I do want to give you a little bit
of preview these are the things that
that Epictetus says this is really what
philosophy is about according to Stoics
these three main studies theories
differing with a lot of other
philosophers and even with some of the
other Stoics who had focused on logic
more or focused more on you know
investigating nature he's very concerned
this is those concerned logic a bit but
but it primarily concerns what we call
ethics and philosophy of human nature a
little bit of epistemology as well we'll
come back to that let's talk about how
do we get doing this whole philosophy
business in the first place so let's
contrast
Epictetus to another philosopher
Aristotle Aristotle had famously said
that philosophy begins in wonder or or
you could call it or amazement and
amazing that what yeah the things that
we encounter like you know looking at
the universe Wow
what is this and we want to figure out
what's actually going on there
that's not where everybody began
philosophy for somebody like even
socrates philosophy began with a much
more humble and human endeavor and you
can say the same thing about epictetus
when he talks about how this philosophy
begins he's got two passages where he
tells you about this the first place he
says the beginning of philosophy to him
at least who enters in it on the right
way because you can't enter it in too
many different ways and by the door as a
post according in the window or digging
up from you know below or something like
that is a consciousness of his own
weakness and inability about necessary
things now doesn't that strike you as
kind of strange to say the consciousness
of our inability and our weakness about
necessary things
Epictetus is saying we need to think
things out precisely because we find
ourselves in a mess and we don't just
find ourselves in a mess in a situation
that that's a mess we find ourselves to
be a mess
and we want to know what kind of things
get this way and if we want to do that
we're gonna require some standard for
not being so screwed up for not having
things so backwards or mixed up and that
standard can't just be our feelings or
our self-esteem or our desires it's got
to be something else
some of them will come from within us
but some was going to come from teaching
as well he says we come into the world
with no notion about a whole bunch of
things for example geometry we you know
we have to be taught geometry in school
but as to good and evil beautiful and
ugly what's appropriate or inappropriate
what's proper and improper happiness and
misfortune what we want to do what we
want not to do whoever came into the
world without some sort of eye
dia about these we all have some sort of
what he's calling preconceptions Pro
leap say something Greek you can
understand these as being sort of born
in us or you can understand it as we all
encounter an environment that imposes
some basic conceptions upon us but these
are vague good and evil we think all
sorts of things are good and evil we're
not even consistent with ourselves over
time quite often we have these really
basic notions these preconceptions but
are they that are they being applied
correctly do we know what to do with
them well or are we miss up lying them
when we get to particulars which is
where we live where we make decisions
actual real existing things or the
things that we imagine are we getting
the application right where are they I
mean you know if we think about our own
experience mm-hmm and we've put it in
these sort of terms and then we often
screwed up great example preconception
of what a friend is is you know it's
supposed to be like we think somebody is
our friend we get down to the
particulars turns out they were our
friend
they screw us over we feel bad as a
result we were angry were upset wherever
saying were hurt we overreact and then
the next time around we refuse to make
ourselves vulnerable to the next person
who comes along still operating on these
preconceptions and we're never going to
get away from preconceptions by the way
we need these we need them in order to
be able to make sense out of reality
according to epictetus but applying them
to particulars is something that isn't
it to us applying them well to
particular I should say and we want to
figure out how we should do this he goes
on a little bit more and he says this is
the beginning of philosophy a perception
of the disagreement of human beings with
each other what's going on there
well we all come into the world with
these preconceptions and you know what
might happen in the case of the false
friend right I have a preconception of
friendship they have a preconception of
friendship we you know these
preconceptions don't disagree with each
other as a matter of fact they kind of
map on to each other but they're there's
a loosey goosy they're not quite
definite they are general you can put a
lot of different things into these boxes
that are these preconceptions and then
when it comes to actually applying
things to particulars I find out that
you know I thought that a friend
shouldn't you know for example this is
not a case that's happened to me think I
shouldn't use my credit card and this
other person over here thinks that
friends should share and share alike and
they get to use my credit card and run
it up very high and now we have a
conflict now I say you're not really a
friend and they say oh yes I am we're
friends and now we have a disagreement
now a philosophy begins when we get
enough of these disagreements that we
start saying I gotta figure this out but
it doesn't just stop there with
disagreement and identifying you know
the sort of structure he says a
perception of the disagreement of people
with each other and an inquiry into the
cause of the disagreement and a
condemnation and distrust of that which
only seems and a certain investigation
of that which seems whether it seems
rightly and a discovery of some rule as
we have discovered a balance in the
determination of weights in a
carpenter's rule he means a measuring
tape in the case of straight and crooked
things this is the beginning of
philosophy so philosophy doesn't just
begin by noting that there's conflict
and it doesn't just begin by saying well
now we understand why there's conflict
you know we've got the same basic ideas
but when it comes to how we flush those
ideas out you and I aren't on the same
page and you know we get down to the
nitty-gritty the particulars where we
live you and I are in disagreement with
each other it doesn't stop there because
you can
ask well who's right is anybody all
right are we all just crazy our wages of
making stuff up as we go along how do I
know how I actually ought to live you
know think about it again these key
issues we all have ideas of the good and
the evil the beautiful and the ugly the
moral and the the immoral the the noble
and the base the becoming and the
unbecoming the appropriate and the
inappropriate happiness misfortune all
these sorts of things what we ought to
do what we ought not to do these are
important things for us to to figure out
and if all we have is a world full of
disagreements where are we going to turn
what we need is some sort of rule for
figuring these things out we need
something to measure whether we're
actually getting the applications right
and how much how much progress needs to
be made yet we need a standard by which
we can make sense of things where are we
going to find them he says you know
let's think about other other areas of
life you know do we have to say that all
things are right which seems so to all
how does it possible contradictions can
be right not all then but which seemed
to us be right well different people
think different things are right so what
are we going to get for that rule
he says there's got to be some rule so
he gives us an example he says what is
the matter presented to us about which
we're inquiring pleasure let's think
about pleasure
we all feel pleasure right now let's
subjective what is really Pleasant
what should we want to feel he says
subject it to the rule throw it into the
balance want the good to be such a thing
that it is fit that we have confidence
in it yeah we get people to agree to
that
and in which we ought to confined yeah
does it fit to trust to anything which
is insecure
not this pleasure is pleasure anything
secure now that I think about it notice
I say now that I actually think about it
a little bit turns out that's not the
case if I'm just going with my gut
reactions I'm condemned to being stuck
here but as a human being we're able to
reflect upon this and gradually make our
way to some sort of rule or standard so
it says to philosophize is this to
examine and to confirm the rules to
figure out what we need to actually get
straight about so we're going to look at
a few different things with with respect
to this let's look at chapter 17 of book
2 now
this is about preconceptions or easy is
it calling they're in the translation
how we're applying preconceptions to
particular cases says what is the first
business of the person who's
philosophizing so now notice he's
bringing in something new if we want to
be able to find the rule and we want to
be able to apply it we have to look at
the kind of people that we are
we can't just sort of get it from the
outside and start applying it the way
that you might by ordering some product
it's got to become part of who we are so
he says the throwaway self-conceit now
what does it mean to throw myself
concede that means to not think that we
always have it right but to be willing
to see if there's something else that
might be more right than us that we
would have to subject ourselves to why
he says well it's impossible for
somebody to begin to learn what they
think that they already know you can't
teach somebody who already thinks that
they know it all because there's
literally no room in their mind for you
to put anything else for them to learn
anything else again you have to if we
want to do philosophy we have to be we
have to be honest about our own
condition about the fact that we don't
have it all
ahead of time so he says as the things
about you know what ought to be done and
what ought not to be done all of us go
talking of them at random you know and
then we go to the philosophers so we go
and we read Plato and we read Aristotle
we read Epictetus and we read other
people and we we buy books and we put
them on the shelf and on these matters
we praise we censure we accuse we blame
we judge and determine about principles
honourable and dishonourable but why do
we go to the philosophers
why did Epictetus go to Musso Gnaeus
Rufus why if you're actually you know
really into this why would you go to a
philosopher because we want to learn
what we think we don't know well what is
that he says it's not possible to adapt
preconceptions that we have to their
correspondent objects if we've not
distinguished them if we've not enquired
what object must be subjected to each
preconception if we're not actually
looking at the world that we live in and
paying attention to it and
distinguishing it and this world that we
live in doesn't just mean things outside
of us it also includes our reactions to
them and how we relate ourselves to
those things and then we also have to
look at our me applying things right or
maybe are other people applying things
better than than we are do they have a
better conception of how to do this so
he says it gives an example of this
again who among us doesn't speak of good
and bad useful and not useful who
doesn't have a preconception of each of
these things you know if you wonder do
we talk about this sort of stuff how did
you end up in college how did you end up
studying this material watching this
video you had a conception of what was
good for you and as you was beginning to
apply it to particular cases you start
saying I should actually watch this
video that would be a good thing for me
a might not be a good thing
you know just for your own development
or something like that I need to pass
this class and if I want to pass this
class I gotta learn the material this is
a useful way of learning the material
you carried out a reasoning process
you're all carrying out reasoning
processes all the time about what's good
and bad right and wrong you're making
judgments constantly if anybody tells
you not to be judgmental or not to make
judgments they're probably manipulating
you or blinding you because you do need
to actually make some judgments and you
need some preconceptions in order to do
that but you want to make sure they're
actually the right ones so he goes and
he says apply the preconception to the
particular things does not one man adopt
the preconception of good - when we're
talking about particulars - well in
another not to wealth but pleasure and
health different people are oriented
towards different goods right and they
all have the preconception of what's
really good for us but when you get down
to the particulars and the application
that they're making of it they come up
with different answers how do you figure
out which one is right how do you come
up with a rule test them walk them
through somebody thinks that well really
is the best thing in the world think
about well think about what you can do
with it think about what you can't do
with it think about you know how it's an
external thing to us and can be taken
away just like that and look around and
see whether wealth really does in fact
make people happy or whether it's the
things that they can buy with it that
they think make them happy and see
whether those they actually make them
happy or not or whether happiness
consists in something else so he says if
you actually properly adapt your
preconceptions you're not going to be
unhappy you're not going to be hindered
so that is a key topic to think about he
says let's put aside the other topics
about pursuits and study of the duties
let's admit the third topic I'm gonna
give you those let's insist on the first
topic and now you realize we're already
starting to get into the course of study
what is the first topic
if present he says it presents an almost
obvious demonstration that we don't
properly adapt preconceptions do you now
desire that which is possible and that
which is possible to you if so why are
you hindered why are you troubled if you
actually have your desires and your
versions right in how you thought it you
know you applying this basic
preconception that you've got about
what's good and bad or desirable or
undesirable if you're actually applying
that right why doesn't your life already
as good as it can be that means that you
need to look at desires and aversions
you need to actually study them you need
to think about them you need to do some
judging you need to start saying maybe
this desire that I am is not a good
desire for me yeah maybe this aversion
that I have is not a good aversion for
me and then after you've realized that
what do you do how do you change that
well he goes and I donate tells us
several other things as well this is in
book 3 he says there's three things in
which a man want to exercise himself
would be wise and good what is this man
translate human being because it's
entrepot so it means human being not
necessarily male gender the first
control concerns the desires and
aversions why so that you won't fail to
get what you desire and so that you
won't fall into what you are averse to
the second concerns movements towards
and movements from an object and in
general doing what a person ought to do
so that you can act according to order
to reason and not carelessly the third
content concerns freedom from deception
and rashness and gentleman and generally
it concerns the assents Nexus which of
these is the most important this one
because that I'm going to do a little
bit of erasing here that doesn't just
concern desire and aversion in the sense
of turning towards or away from
something it also has to do with
calls the effects and when you see an
effect think emotion or mood or attitude
when you get angry you get angry because
you're averse to something that somebody
imposed upon you or your averse to the
thing being imposed on you in the way
that it was or the fact that they
overlooked you or that they hinder you
and you have a desire to retaliate anger
can be understood it has not only a set
of beliefs and not only a feeling but
also desires and aversions anger arises
because our desires and aversions are
are vexed or crossed same thing with
sadness
same thing with fear same thing with all
these these emotions that we can think
of so he says an effect is produced in
no other way than by failing to obtain
what what a person desires are falling
into what a person would wish to avoid
that's what brings in perturbations
getting upset disorders bad fortune
misfortunes sorrows lamentations and
envy that's what makes people envious
and jealous and by these causes were
unable to listen to the precepts of
reason reason is what makes us the kind
of beings that we are so then he says
the second topic concerns the duties of
a person I don't want to just be free
from the effects like a statue I would
actually be an active person who does
the things that I ought to do I had to
maintain the relations natural and
acquired as a pious person a son a
father a citizen the third topic he says
is that which immediately concerns those
who are getting somewhere that which
concerns the security of the other two
and it has to do with what we should
give a set to which we should agree to
and what we might get deceived by so
this has got some epistemology and some
logic parts there you know Epictetus
says a lot of people want to be in
philosophy here like with a critical
thinking class or something like that
and they don't pay attention to getting
this stuff
right this is really sort of the icing
on the cake this is what consolidates
these other two but people want to begin
with this he says the president
philosophers they neglect the first two
they employ themselves on the second and
if they employ themselves on the third
and they they get you know nowhere as a
result she says have you successfully
worked out the rest here are some
examples again are you free from
deception in the matter of money do you
really understand what money is about
and whether it can make you happy or not
you see a attractive person do you
resist the appearance if a neighbor
obtains an estate by will somebody you
know succeeds somebody wins the lottery
do you feel envious he says now is there
nothing else you know wanting to you
that you're lacking except some
unchangeable firmness of mind you hear
these very things with fear and anxiety
that some person may despise you and
with inquiries what any person may say
about you and a person comes and tells
you that in a certain question in which
the question was who's the best
philosopher somebody who is present said
that a certain person was the best
philosopher your little soul which was
only a fingers like stretched stretches
out two feet so what he's saying is
unless we actually get this stuff
figured out what you got it has to do
with how to apply preconceptions to
particulars Wow
that's the key I yeah this this is
providing us for the rule unless we
actually do that we're not going to get
anything out of this other type of study
and he says you know if you want to know
what a person is really like look at
their principles look at what fits in
here as what motivates them we'd like to
think that we're more than just our
principles or desires or versions or
motivations but really if you want to
know who a person is look at
they desire bringing out some around
said if you want to know who a person is
look at what they eat where we are what
we eat in a certain respect right and
that's true but we are also what we read
what we watch what we imitate who we
hang out with what we place is central
to us and we're not that different from
each other in these respects one person
who's money-hungry is pretty much the
same as another person who's
money-hungry
in how they're going to adapt their
preconceptions of the good or the
appropriate or the right to particulars
and screw it up in the process one
person who's who's trying to live out of
stoic life is very much like another
person who's trying to live out a stoic
life doesn't keep them from being
individuals but these are pretty common
topics there's one other thing that he
says about about this stalking about
this is in Chapter 12 of book 3 about
exercise what does exercise mean well
you know when you exercise your body
you're trying to improve it right and
can you you know benchpress 250 pounds
just by saying you know this week I can
only benchpress 95 pounds next week it's
going to be 250 that's not gonna happen
you have to work your way up it takes a
lot of time some people may never be
able to do that
am I gonna you know I'm never gonna run
a 5 and a half minute mile again like I
did whatever this 19 years old this is
not going to happen but you know it was
just assuming that I was going to be
inclined towards running which I'm not I
can't actually you know do exercise that
will increase my cardiovascular level
and strengthen my legs and things like
that but it has to be gradual he says
since strong habit leads and were
accustomed to employ desire and aversion
only to things which are not in the
power of our will we ought to oppose to
this habit a contrary habit where
there's great slipperiness in
appearances there to oppose they have
of exercise what would be an example of
this he has the example of pleasure
great example for me look to eat I'd
love to taste things I love to cook I
probably eat larger portions than I
ought to why do I do that because I like
the pleasure of actually eating the food
most often made by by myself I want to
get better just as far as my body goes
but also in terms of my self control in
my mind what I got to do is oppose the
habit that I've already developed of
desiring certain things and being averse
to certain things what we're not going
to have dessert you know I like to have
dessert you know with with dinner and I
have an aversion to not having dessert
that's kind of stupid isn't it I could
easily say look buddy we're just not
going to have dessert for the next month
and by the end of that month I will
probably have changed my aversion so
it's not really a problem for me anymore
what gets us to do that we have to
choose it we have to actually have a
desire that bears upon our desires we
have to have an aversion to having crazy
aversions notice there's some what we
call reflexivity there so he says that
if we want to change the way we are we
need to focus not only on acquiring
information we have to actually do some
some exercise this is something that we
acquire how to apply preconceptions to
particular as well we acquire that in
part by doing it over and over and over
again we need a rule for it but it's a
kind of rule when it comes to these
things that's only going to become
apparent as such over time it's not
going to be fully apparent to us from
the start
until we're already engaged in it that's
the beginning of philosophy for
epictetus